this video is brought to you by secret
lab
what's going on guys it's bobby and i am
back talking about another transformer i
know uh a lot of you had um
various opinions on the ark review that
we did here some enjoyed our sense of
humor others wanted a more serious
review
so i have taken some of your notes and
we're going to apply it to our next
unboxing and review
notice i said the word unboxing because
a lot of you on the comments have said
do you steal these transformers are you
getting up in the factory illegally how
are you getting them first off i want to
thank hasbro singapore thank you hasbro
for sending these over to geek culture
this is
the box
for rodimus prime i think we're the only
channel showing the box because we get
ours legally now not to say the others
don't because i do not know them we have
no idea
but ours comes from hasbro
here's the box herodomus prime
so thank you hospital singapore for this
and so with that guys
let's talk about radames prime and of
course we have the arc and we have
galvatron here but there's been a number
of videos on galvatron we'll touch base
with him a little bit but it's all about
radimus prime today you got the touch
ding ding ding
you got the power
zach you actually have a really good
voice man
thank you maybe we have to do maybe you
know exactly i'm thinking just put this
aside like for a second i think we need
to do something with
the touch i mean this is the figure we
have to do it for right right should we
roll the thing we should roll the thing
let's roll it
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's get into this
beautiful artwork on the front
move to the side it continues on each of
the sides
great sort of movie poster uh kingdom
war of cybertron's trilogy right there
then we come to the back rottenness
prime the matrix
various different uh tools going on
there
you've got his trailer with the weapons
official box
from hasbro
okay
now let's get into this first off i do
want to show you with something very
cool it's interesting inside the
instruction manual here when you get
this out you are going to get this
holographic card of optimus prime okay
kingdom war of warfare cybertron trilogy
right there turn on the back
from hasbro
look at that
this is what you get
out of the retail packaging
from hasbro for rodimus prime
just to let you guys know
we didn't steal this
okay
moving on we have the instruction manual
here of course you have your uh various
different languages and safety sheets
but nonetheless
we've got
radimus
in the box
i'm going in more detail now because a
lot of you said that we rushed through
the whole unboxing and the
transformation on the last one so i felt
okay guys
fair enough a lot of you said this
i will learn and adapt and make this in
detail right zacky we listen to our our
fans here don't we we care we care we
care a lot about what you guys say okay
here's the trailer we'll put that to the
side first
here is the uh
gun
setup right there
looks like a pseudo tank and a gun right
there that goes under there now we're
going to remove rodamus prime and that
releases everything of course we've got
these straps here
around rodamus which you can actually
remove by hand
just sort of sort of wrapped around
there's rodimus prime
and then here are some accessories his
guns and
various different things
and there
out of the way
first impressions
okay
i'm a huge fan of the 86 movie i
actually went to the movie theater and
watched the movie there as a kid i'm
kind of sharing with you how old i am
but nonetheless i'm a big g1 fan and of
course hot rod rod on his prime when
optimus was killed
i cried i was shocked that they did this
so soon but they did it first
impressions this is really really nice
this spoiler wing right here is really
well made
great
detail in this
i don't know is this metal it feels like
it might be a metal or really hard
plastic whatever it is it's really
strong the hood on this the paint is
beautiful on the hood um this is no
decal at all i don't know what kind
someone asked me in the comments is this
some is it paint or is it some sort of
stampography i honestly i don't know i
don't work in a factory but it's paint
to me
you guys might know more than i do in
regards to how they make these
transformers but it looks really good i
do love the blue right here it does give
it a nice contrast uh with the the
orange and the yellow with the red um i
like that quite a bit
um the wheels everything spins the
exhaust pipes on the side all look
really good
yeah actually i think this is metal
jackie this feels
might be i don't know anyway it feels
really good um
so
just in this car form rodimus prime a
plus
um
has some weight to it too which is
really nice now the trailer is
interesting because it's got a lot of
these grooves right here which i don't
know what goes in there per se maybe
this is something that we'll add in the
future with various different
accessories um i kind of wish that
this was a little bit less because it
does in a way sort of
i don't want to say it cheapens the look
of it but it doesn't give it that sense
of quality that we're seeing like
abortimus right here
but nonetheless maybe there's a reason
for it and i just don't know it yet
in terms of this gun turret right here
uh
yeah
paint on it's pretty good it's got a
black fade to silver on that looks legit
the detail here with the uh
the tank belt and the wheels all looks
good now these can it does not roll here
um it's just there for show but it does
look legit and we'll put that on there
in just a bit and of course we have the
accessories in here
because we got where's the matrix at man
is it inside radomus maybe it's inside
rodamus
because i'm not seeing it in here right
now we got the sword
and the sword looks like okay there's a
little bit of a groove there i think to
push out where you can put
in someone's hand i think maybe not
looks like there's some sort of hinge
there but anyway there's the sword
very detailed well sculpted
uh
looks like some blasters of some sort
now these blasters that we had on the
ark didn't really stick
hopefully they fare better on rodamus
prime but there's a series of different
um kind of like that exhaust blasters in
the background this sort of uh
star thing i don't know exactly what
this is yet i haven't looked at the
manual
these black
sort of flames bits again i haven't this
is a first unboxing i haven't done any
sort of research and looked into the
manual yet so
i will get to more of the
the actual names of these items in just
a bit of course this is his weapon his
gun right there looks really good very
detailed um does hinge on that's very
nice so there we have that so i'm
guessing
the matrix
is inside rodamus prime
because i'm not seeing anywhere else
okay so let's start from the trailer in
terms of transforming it as i mentioned
here with the gun you can actually put
it in various different holes depending
on where it is now this is not the most
uh when you do turn this out it does
wanna
tend to flex quite easily so you're
gonna have to put some
you know a little bit of force on to
lock it in
and then with this gun turret you could
turn down turn it around
it does a 360 on this as well and the
hinge area here it's pretty uh
maneuverable on this so that's pretty
cool and then when it's done it's over
but a lot of people are actually putting
this inside the trailer which you can do
but according to the instruction manual
you can put it on top the trailer as
well so i'll show you how that works in
just a bit just pull that out so to
kind of keep this in
you lock that in which takes a little
bit of force
close up the hatch here
pull this here now one thing you're
going to notice on the back
is this the this flap doesn't tend to
want to stay
completely flat on it so
um at least on our unit here so there's
no way to sort of force it or lock it in
it's just sort of stuck there so
it's a little bit loose on that
not a deal breaker but something to take
note of
then you just close the flaps here
there
oh zach here we go you have to really
snap things in so
you really have to squeeze this in so
it's not something that just
automatically closes right away you're
going to find some gaps so just to
squeeze the back in squeeze the doors in
really kind of compress it all in once
you're there you got a nice seal on that
then of course you pull this portion up
this door up and you're good to go as
for the gun
according to hasbro you've got two
levers at the bottom of this you've got
this sort of
flat squarish
leg and then you have the round peg
right so the round peg
will go
here
and again
as i said this peg is not the strongest
thing so you got to just sort of push
that in there
this square area that square peg there
will hold there and then of course
this can stay
on top the trailer so you can have it
like that as well okay and
these uh levers also turn so if you want
to know about that that's how it is okay
now let's put the uh blasters or say the
let's say the afterburner what do you
call this zacky what do you call these
things that comes on the back of the
pipes
exhaust exhaust flames yeah exhaust
flames it's blue
okay we'll put those here
so they stick on pretty well
don't think those will come out much
better than the ark and i guess you have
various different
sizes so if you want to play mix and
match with that i guess you can do so
uh
yeah
looks legit
really fast
let's try the other side but
oops
watch out for that tray that will come
out with that that also helps you pull
out the tray by the way
so
yeah if you want to like
one bigger than the other you can do
that as well so you can mix and match
play around with that as you want just a
fun little thing to do but we'll just
put the standard ones there
just for aesthetic and of course does
help us remove the tray if we need to
so speaking of tray we'll remove the
tray for this really cool thing this is
actually a little storage unit
underneath and there's uh grooves that
you can actually put these in
so what you just do is you push that in
like that
and then these smoke stack uh
pieces you put in like this
once it's in there then you actually
just slide it in the bottom
of the trailer
like so
and you can store those pieces if you're
not going to use them and we'll take our
black exhaust pieces
put this tray back in
so
what you do is
you're supposed to match it accordingly
like that
so there you put them on
black flames on the side or black smoke
i should say
i should have made it red though
yeah they could have made it red i guess
you know you're right they could have
done red but then again it would blend
in with the trailer so you have the
black smoke coming out of the smoke
stacks here the exhaust on the trailer
now here's something very interesting on
this that uh
yonko over here geek culture did
recognize and it missed me missed my on
my eye on this if we go back to the box
and you're only going to know this if
you get the actual retail box okay
is that on the box
this this smoke stack is actually
clear
but on this one
it's black
so this could be is this a mistake from
hasbro is this a variant you know
because sometimes they make these
mistakes you know in the factory then
all of a sudden they do a short run and
then they fix it
so
yeah this could be a mistake
because it should technically be clear
according to the box
keep that in mind there are no mistakes
only happy little accidents
is that what your mom told you during
potty training
that's so i'm sorry sorry zack that just
came out of my mind man sorry okay
so anyway
that's the trailer let's attach rodimus
prime it's very simple with these wings
this is actually going to help you like
so you line it up accordingly
so kind of make sure that it's split
down the middle
push it in
you hear a little bit of a snap
and
you're locked in
not all the wheels turn so the back
wheels are working these middle wheels
for some reason are not hitting the
ground if i push down on it
really solid then yes now it works right
you've got to push down on the trailer
and the front wheels are not so yeah
again
not a deal breaker but if you want
perfection
this is not it
but
for most of you you're not going to be
rolling it around on the ground well if
you're a kid you are going to play
around with it but if you're an adult
and you're collecting this you're going
to either keep it in
you know in this form or in his uh
transformer mode and leave it at that so
yeah not a deal breaker and if you want
to remove them just pull them right out
and there is rodimus prime so before i
attempt to transform rodamus prime it's
always good to be comfortable
transforming a transformer that's why we
choose secret lab chairs now secret lab
chairs come in a variety of different
sizes and of course in different
materials pu leather 2.0 full grain
leather and of course soft weave and
various different designs so you have
everything from relationships with game
of thrones to dc you have batman you
have joker your harley quinn a variety
of collaborations with many different uh
gamers out there there is a chair for
everyone at secret lab and plus they now
make a desk speaking of transformers
they actually have a name that sounds
like a transformer it's called magnus it
comes in a 1.5 meter length i heard
there's a 1.7 coming in the near future
there's also a 1.3 meter available as
well so do check out their website at
secretlab.com
okay guys
let's get back to transforming rodimus
prime
so now i'm going to transform rotomus
prime in to his
robot mode
according to the instruction manual it's
about 30 steps they're about so this is
more difficult than the ark
and i have to say this is uh
you know with all these instruction
manuals
if you're like me you're somewhat new to
transforming these newer pieces
they're not the easiest to always
understand so it's gonna be a lot of
trial and error but let's get down to it
lock that into place here
and
voila there's rodamus prime
so overall in terms of the
transformation on this pretty well
engineer to be honest with you there's a
lot of little steps with this it's not
the easiest thing this is definitely for
more experienced collectors and more
experienced people that are used to
transforming uh transformers per se um
it looks great transformed as you can
totally tell it's a beautiful sculpt
looks
looks really really good
but it
a little bits and pieces and you do have
to make sure they have to adjust those
wheels because especially in the legs if
you do not push the wheels in all the
way you're going to have a hard time
folding the legs out and actually
putting them in place so do keep note of
that
but overall i really like the look
of rodimus prime this is a very
impressive figure right here he looks
really really good um i love the gloss
paint on his legs and also on the chest
piece here which is the hood of the car
because it looks really good as well and
it complements the wings or the spoiler
because it gives it this sense that it
is more metallic and i think it might be
some sort of metallic composite here
it's hard to say
maybe this not i don't know i really
don't know to be honest with you because
it's sort of that kind of material where
it could be metal
or it could be plastic but it's a very
high grade the paintwork is beautiful on
this
the details all the way through the arms
and everything else
and the the face sculpt is not like the
86 okay this is a much more angular more
i would say mature version of radomus
obviously in the 86 movie he had more of
a rounder face really good presence to
him um the legs
maneuverability everything is really
good on that as well
love the color i kind of wish the legs
were a little bit more gloss black to
kind of match the
the thigh area here but that's just my
personal opinion on this as a matter of
fact
i would say this figure would have been
great and maybe somebody will do this
is if they just sort of do a gloss coat
over the red and everything else
because it would just scream
quality even more
as you can tell from the transformation
it's not the easiest there's a lot of
little
pieces that you've got to really
maneuver and really sort of
click into place and it can be a bit
convoluted i mean i think hasbro did an
admirable job with what they could on a
paper instruction manual there are some
little uh things that if you do miss it
kind of screws the whole thing up as a
whole when you transform it and get it
to its robot form as you can see we've
got the sword on the back which you can
also put on the hand we got the gun here
but i'm going to put take out the matrix
and we will also show you what that
looks like as well by the way case in
point this piece
is attached to the matrix i found that
out looking at the instruction manual so
when he pulls the matrix apart
and the matrix it gets you know kind of
uh
illuminates
that's what this piece is for so uh you
guys probably already know that by now
but nonetheless i'm discovering this as
i'm going through this first unboxing
with you so to show you what the matrix
looks like you just uh drop down his
chest piece the matrix is in a side of
his chest right there and you just have
to sort of
use your
fingernails or your fingers or if you
don't have fingernails then
use a tool to get that out because it is
and they're pretty good
it's really in there solid there we go
matrix fell out
where the matrix go wow
the matrix almost went underneath the
shelf doesn't this happen when we take
toys apart sculpt on the matrix is very
nice
uh as you can see very good detail on
that then of course what you'll do is
you take this piece
it doesn't stick that well to be honest
with you so
once you're in there you're in there the
trick to this is and they show in the
structure manual is to actually
with this uh
illumination piece
put rodamus's hands around the matrix
which you can do because
the index finger is articulate the other
fingers are joined together and the
thumb is static so that one index finger
is sort of going to be your anchor point
to make sure that this is locked into
place you know honestly speaking
this is quite difficult all right this
is adult level transformation i mean i
think a child would have a hard time
with this so
adult level transformation
i don't know about you i don't know
where i come up with this stuff man i
really don't know man i mean come on
there we go
you got the touch bam
you got the power
galvatron you don't get the matrix no
you don't but they fought and then
rodimus picked them up and threw them
out the ship
simple as that uh i'm a big fan i think
for any collector out there you've got
to get rod of his
he just looks
amazing in my personal opinion love the
sculpt on the face i think hasbro has
improved him from what it was in the 86
movie but i think everything's been
improved since the 86 movie i mean
that's 1986 or 2021 so animation
drawings everything but they did a
really good job with that and galvatron
pretty legitimate speaking of which got
a funny story about megatron and
galvatron
i think i know why they changed megatron
from a handgun
to galvatron right and it's not from the
movie but i think honestly it's because
a lot of kids including myself were
walking around megatron in gun format
around town and it was a metal it was a
metal piece of equipment right it looked
legit from far it looked like a real gun
because it was designed after a real gun
anyway funny story um
that i was traveling one day with my
parents we were flying from las vegas to
pennsylvania
and to see my grandparents and so i had
you know as a big transformers collector
back in the day and i had all my
transformers in my duffel bag i was
gonna play on the plane with you know to
do with them and i had megatron as the
gun
in the bag well guess what happens when
you go through security and they scan
your bag
and they see a handgun
security rushes me and my parents and
they're like can we see your bag please
and uh they open the bag and they see a
handgun and i'm like no no no that's a
transformer that's megatron let me show
you i'm like a little kid at this point
in time i'm like 10 years old or nine or
ten and they're like
do not touch the bag
they pull up they pull out the gun and i
said can i please show you can i please
show you so i
went ahead and showed them
and they kind of slapped me smirked and
they said okay look you can't take this
on the plane with you
because this looks like a gun and if you
take it out it's going to be a security
issue so
you'll have to you know check it in and
then you can pick it up when you arrive
so i have a feeling
that maybe for security and for safety
reasons
they changed megatron to galvatron for
for that alone because yeah a kid
walking around with a handgun that was
kind of was made out of metal at that
time anyway
yeah it wasn't uh probably the most
safest toy to have
right if a police officer sees you
they're gonna think something's up
anyway those are just my thoughts fun
little story of my uh my journey with
megatron those are my thoughts on
radimus prime gabatron looks pretty cool
as well let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below hopefully this
video is a little bit more serious for
you guys out there who were you know
commenting though i was cracking too
many corny jokes on the previous one but
we have some fun here don't we zacky we
like to have fun exactly because you
want to know why these are toys
it's about bringing back our childhood
and we gotta have a laugh it's geek
culture
exactly hence the name of the channel
all right guys with that stay safe take
care and i'll chat you in the next one
bye
[Music]
you